- [Voiceover] We should talk a little more
about Newtons's Third Law,
because there are some deep misconceptions
that many people have about this law.
It seems simple, but it's not nearly
as simple as you might think.
So people often phrase it as,
for every action there's an
equal and opposite reaction.
But that's just way
too vague to be useful.
So a version that's a little better,
says that for every
force, there's an equal
and opposite force.
So this is a little better.
The equal sign means that these forces
are equal in magnitude.
And this negative sign
means they're just different
by the direction of the vector.
So these are vectors, so
this says that this pink
vector F, has the opposite direction,
but equal in magnitude
to this green vector F.
But to show you why this is
still a little bit too vague,
consider this, if this
is all you knew about
Newtons's Third Law, that for every force,
there's an equal and opposite force,
you might wonder, if you were clever,
you might be like, wait a minute,
if for every force F,
right, there's got to be
a force that's equal and opposite.
Well why doesn't that just mean
that every force in the universe cancels?
Shouldn't every force just
cancel then, at that point?
Doesn't that just mean that there's
no acceleration that's even possible?
Because if I go and exert
a force F on something,
if there's gonna be a force negative F,
doesn't that mean that no
matter what force I put forward,
it's just gonna get cancelled?
And the answer no, and the reason it's no
is because these two forces
are exerted on different objects.
So you have to be careful.
So the reason I say that this statement
of Newtons's Third Law is
still a little bit too vague,
is because this is really
on different objects.
So if this is the force on object A,
exerted by object B,
then this force over here
has to be the force on object
B, exerted by object A.
In other words, these
forces down here are exerted
on different objects.
I'm gonna move this over to this side.
I'm gonna move this over to here.
Let's draw two different objects
to show explicitly what I mean.
So if there was some object A,
so I put some object A in here.
Just wanna make sure there's an object A.
Let's say this is object A, and it had
this green force exerted on it, F.
So this object right here is A.
Well, there's gonna be
another object, object B.
We'll just make it another circle.
So we'll make it look like this.
So here's object B.
And it's gonna have this pink force,
F, negative F exerted on it.
So I'm gonna call this object B.
Now we're okay, now we know
these forces can't cancel,
and the reason these forces can't cancel,
is cause they're on two different objects.
But when you just say
that Newtons's Third Law,
is that every force has an
equal and opposite force,
it's not clear that it has
to be on different objects.
But it does have to be
on different objects.
So these Newtons force law pairs,
often times is called force pairs,
or Newton's third law partner forces,
are always on different objects.
So the convention I'm using
is that the first letter
represents the object
that the force is on.
So this A represents
that this green force F
this green force F, is on
A and it's exerted by B.
And this shows that it's exerted on B,
because the first
letter's on the first one,
and it's exerted by the second object, A.
So this pink force is exerted on B.
This green force is exerted on A.
They're equal and opposite,
they do not cancel,
they cannot cancel because
they're not on the same object.
So that's why these don't cancel.
And they are the same magnitude,
even if the two objects
are not the same size.
This is another misconception,
if object A is a planet, a big planet.
Or maybe a star, this is
yellow, it looks like a star.
Let's say this is some big star,
and this is some smaller
planet orbiting that star.
This is not to scale, unless
this planet was enormous.
So this is some planet,
but this planet could be
hundreds, thousands of
times, millions of times
less massive than this
star but it would still
exert the same force.
So if this star is pulling on the planet
with this pink force negative F,
then this planet has to
be pulling on the star
with this green force
F and they have to have
the same magnitude, even if
they are different sizes.
So people quote Newtons's Third Law,
but sometimes they
don't really believe it.
If I told you this planet
was a million times
less massive than this star,
people would want to say
that well, then the star obviously
pulls more on the planet,
than the planet pulls on the star.
But that's not true according
to Newtons's Third Law.
And Newtons's Third Law says
that they have to be the same,
even if they're different sizes.
So if this was the earth
and this was the moon,
the earth pulls on the moon, just as much
as the moon pulls on the earth.
And you might still object, you might say,
wait that makes no sense, I
know the star just basically
sits there and the planet gets
whipped around in a circle.
How come this planet's
getting whipped around
and the star's just staying put?
That's because, just because
the forces are equal,
that doesn't mean that
the result is equal.
In other words, the forces could be equal,
but the accelerations
don't have to be equal.
Acceleration is gonna be the
net force divided by the mass.
So even if the force is the same,
you divide by that mass, you'll get
a different acceleration
and that's why the result of
the force does not have to be the same,
even though the forces
do have to be the same,
because of Newtons's Third Law.
Another misconception
people sometimes make,
is they think there might
be a delay in the creation
of this Newtons's Third Law partner force.
And people think, maybe if
I exert this first force
fast enough, I can catch
the universe sleeping,
and there might be some sort of delay
in the creation of this other force.
But that's not true, Newtons's
Third Law is universal.
No matter what the situation,
no matter what the acceleration
or non acceleration,
or motion or no motion, whether one object
is bigger or smaller, if
their Newtons's Third Law
partner forces, they are
equal they are opposite
and they are always equal and opposite,
at every given moment in time.
So even if I came in all guns a blazing,
Chuck Norris style, trying
to dropkick some wall.
That does not look like the
correct form for a drop kick.
But even if I came in,
flying at this wall,
as soon as I start to make
contact with the wall,
I'm gonna exert a force on the wall,
and the wall has to exert a force back.
So I'd exert a force on
the wall to the right.
And this would be the force
on the wall, by my foot.
There'd have to be an
equal and opposite force
instantly transmitted
backwards, on my foot.
So this would be the force
on my foot, by the wall.
This happens instantaneously,
there is no delay.
You can't kick this wall fast enough,
for this other force to not
be generated instantaneously.
As soon as your foot starts
to exert any force on the wall
what so ever, the wall
is gonna start exerting
that same force back on your foot.
So Newtons's Third Law is universal,
but people still have trouble identifying
these third law partner forces.
So one of the best ways to do it,
is by listing both objects,
as soon as you list both objects,
well to figure out where
the partner force is,
you can just reverse these labels.
So I know over here, if one of my forces
is the force on the wall by my foot,
to find the partner force to this force,
I can just reverse the
labels and say it's gotta be
the force on my foot, by the
wall, which I drew over here.
So this is a great way to identify
the third law partner forces,
cause it's not always obvious
what force is the partner force.
So to show you how this can be tricky,
consider this example.
Say we got the ground and a table.
So this example drives
people crazy for some reason.
If I've got a box sitting on a table,
we'll call it box A.
Box A is gonna have forces exerted on it.
One of those forces is gonna
be the gravitational force.
So the force of gravity is
gonna pull straight down
on box A, and if I were to ask you,
what force is the third law
partner force to this force
of gravity, I'm willing to
bet a lot of people might say,
well there's an upwards force on box A,
exerted by the table.
And that's true.
And if this box A is just sitting here,
not accelerating, these
two forces are going
to be equal and opposite.
So it's even more tempting
to say that these two forces
are equal and opposite
because of the third law,
but that's not true.
These two forces are equal and opposite
because of the second law.
The second law says if
there's no acceleration,
then the net force has to be zero,
the forces have to cancel.
And that's what's happening here.
These forces are equal and opposite,
they're canceling on box A.
Which is a way to know
that they are not third law
partner forces, cause
third law partner forces
are always exerted on different objects.
They can never cancel if they're
third law partner forces.
So what's going on over here?
We've got two forces that are canceling,
that are equal and opposite,
but they're not third law
partner forces, they're partner
forces are somewhere else.
I haven't drawn their partner forces yet.
So let's try to figure out what
they're partner forces are.
So let's get rid of this,
let's come back to here,
let's slow it down to figure
out what the partner force is,
name the two objects interacting.
So this force of gravity,
I shouldn't be vague,
I should call it the force on object A,
our box A exerted by, well
you can't just say gravity.
Gravity is not an object.
So the object that is exerting
this gravitational force
on A, is the earth.
So this force really,
this gravitational force,
if I wanna be careful,
is the force on object A
exerted by the earth.
Now it's easy to figure out
where the partner force is.
The partner force can be found just
by reversing these labels.
So instead of the force on A by the earth,
there's gotta be an
equal and opposite force,
which is the force on the earth, by box A.
So opposite means it has to point up.
So it has to be an upward force.
And that upward force has
to be exerted on the earth,
by box A, and this is kind of weird,
because you may not have realized it,
but if the earth is pulling
down on a box, or you,
that means you are
pulling up on the earth.
And this might seem ridiculous,
I mean if you jump up, you
jump up, you fall back down,
you move around, but the
earth just sits there.
If your forces are equal,
how come the earth doesn't
move around like you do.
And again, it's because just because
the forces are the same, the acceleration
doesn't have to be the same.
The mass of the earth is so big,
compared to your mass, there's
basically no acceleration.
Even though the forces on you
and the forces on the earth are the same.
So these two are third law partner forces.
These two are joined together forever.
They have to be equal,
no matter what happens,
these two forces will always be equal.
I don't care if this box is accelerating
or not accelerating, or that
there's motion or no motion.
Whether it's hitting a
wall, sitting on a table,
falling through space,
these two forces must
always be equal and opposite,
because of the third law.
So how about this other force,
this force that the table was exerting.
So this is, the force on A by the table.
So if I wanna label it correctly,
I'd call it the force on
box A, exerted by the table.
Now finding the third law
partner force is easy,
I can just reverse these labels,
and I'd get that there must be,
instead of an upwards force, a downwards
force on the table, by A.
So I'm gonna have another
force here on the table.
It's gonna be a downward force.
Downward force on the table by A,
that's the third law
partner force to this upward
force that the table is exerting.
These two forces are also
third law partner forces.
these forces are going to be equal
and opposite no matter what happens.
This force on box A by the table.
And this force on the table by box A
must be equal no matter what happens,
but the force on box A by the table,
does not have to be equal and opposite
to the force on A by the earth.
It happens to be equal and opposite,
in a case where there's no acceleration.
If we stuck this whole
situation into an elevator,
or a rocket that had some
huge acceleration upwards,
even if there's acceleration upwards,
these partner forces have to be equal.
So the force on A by the table,
and the force on the table
by A will have to be equal.
Similarly the force on the earth by A,
and the force on A by the
earth have to be equal.
But no longer will these
two forces have to be equal,
cause they're not partner forces.
They might be equal and
opposite in some circumstances,
but they don't always have
to be equal and opposite.
If we're accelerating upwards,
this upward force on the box,
must be bigger than the
downwards force on the box.
So these won't be equal.
Recapping quickly, Newtons's
Third Law is a statement
about the forces on two different objects.
And because it's about
two different objects,
those forces can never cancel.
To find the Newtons's
Third Law partner force,
just reverse the label
after you've identified
the two objects that are interacting.
The third law partner forces
have to be equal in magnitude,
even if one object is
larger than the other,
or has more charge or
any property that might
seem like it would convey more
force, than another object.
If those are the two objects interacting,
their forces must be of equal magnitude
and opposite directions,
the forces instantaneously
generated this partner forces.
And be careful, some forces
might seem like partner forces,
and might be equal and opposite,
but they're not necessarily
third law partner forces.
They made just be equal and
opposite for other reasons.